the jurgen experience
the pig thing i'm glad you brought that
up because that is one thing that i keep
hearing out here from folks
that uh there's an attitude about pigs
that they're disgusting
they're just dirty creatures and they
kind of just want them dead
and uh i've talked to people that go
helicopter hunting
and uh i go what do you do with all the
pigs and they're like you leave them
there
and i'm like what yeah i'm like that
doesn't seem
that seems not just wasteful but well
you know i mean there's a lot to that
you have to have right because of the
so you have to eradicate a certain
amount of those pigs but yeah isn't
there
like a lot of food that you're just
letting rot there is
so i mean you've this is the this is the
pandora's box topic for me
um i'm i'm very vested in it i just
wrote a book about
feral hogs um steve vanella to come full
circle on that and he called me
the hog apologist um
and it's true but to to your point i
think that you know we'll start we'll
start there
with uh a feral hog let's explain the
numbers too
so people need to know how how [ __ ]
crazy it is yes
and and and of course these numbers are
not going to be
clearly defined you know that it's hard
to get a census on hogs so the estimate
uh in the united states is around 6
million
the estimate here in texas is between 2
and 4 million
so probably somewhere in the middle of
that maybe 2.6 that's a number that
you'll see a lot
maybe around 3 million but whatever so
literally
more than the entire population of
austin
in hogs spread out around around
the state and in the time we've been
talking about them
you know how many have been born yeah
so they have no breeding season
they can breed at a very young age um
you know let's say
five or six months is is very
conceivable
um and then they have a gestation period
of three months three weeks three days
and then they can drop a litter of you
know always three days so you can
just plan it out yeah i mean it's pretty
pretty precise like that
i bet women are very jealous yeah yeah
yeah
well i'll be giving birth on wednesday
yeah got a timed in
and after that i mean they're they're
able to go back into
estrus pretty quickly after that and
their litter size can be anywhere
uh from you know two to twelve but you
know let's just say it's you know
even six is a lot so you've got a you've
got a
ten month old animal dropping
six babies and they can do it three
times a year
well twice you know that'll the way that
works out you know you've got i think
it's 20
i want to say 26 days that they can go
back into estrus something like that
it might be 23 days i can't remember the
number right now
after they give birth and they're back
in estrus and if if they're living in an
area that's got a high population of
bores
they're probably going to get bred
pretty quick and so that's when you see
this explosion that has happened and so
they're not indigenous to this country
so they came here in the mid-1500s
columbus brought some to i mean just the
caribbean islands
but the mainland was it's usually
attributed to hernando de soto
who dropped off a bunch of pigs on his
way and before he died in arkansas
and then there was some other uh
explorers that also brought in picks
spanish explorers that brought in you
know domestic semi-domestic
hogs and dropped them off and so what we
saw was this real slow build
in pig populations there was also some
pacific islanders that dropped them off
in hawaii
way before that so if you're talking
about the technical united states
why did they drop them off in hawaii
it's food source no no when
when oh oh it was it was uh i couldn't
give you a number it's
way previous to the 1500s wow that's
wild
so that's a weird debate in hawaii right
because a lot of people are saying
they're an invasive species
yeah and then some folks like well so
are people sure
because if you think about it the hog's
been there as long as the people almost
there's going to be a lot of parallels
yeah yeah there's a
a very destructive european animal
arrives on our shores so
yeah and and now there's a lot of them
so you know you've got these populations
exploding
throughout time but really kind of
concentrated in the late
you know 1900s you know like the 80s and
then you saw people
uh you know you've got a guy that loves
to hunt on his ranch in west texas and
he says
to his friend in east texas he's like
sure as hell i'd like to be able to
shoot something out here year round
buddy in east texas is like wow man i
got some pigs
and then you know traps a couple throws
them on a trailer
and now you have 253 out of 254 counties
in texas have hogs
feral hogs wow and they're spreading all
across the country too right yeah
there's a downward migration from
saskatchewan you know
and those are escaped domestic hawks but
i mean let's also define what a feral
hog is
it's a it's a pig that's just on the
wrong side of a fence
i mean once they get out that's a feral
pig
so i like to say it's a it's a domestic
pig or a feral hog is just a pig without
an address
you know they just as soon as they get
out of that pin
they're feral and i will readily admit i
mean not even on purpose but we have
shot while hunting pigs that had ear
tags you know
meaning that at one point that was a
farm pig it's not anymore
and what it's doing is it's breeding
like crazy
out there with with a feral bore and
it's just creating more feral pigs so
like i said once they're on the wrong
side of the fence they're fair game well
we should explain to people what happens
to pigs right
i've talked about it on the podcast
before but if people haven't heard that
episode
there's a physiological change that
happens to pigs when they get wild so
when you're saying
that this these are pigs they're wild
pigs people like wait but they're bores
boards are different than pigs
it's all called sue scrafa right correct
correct and once they escape within
months
their hair can become shaggy and we're
talking about the same pig you know not
its offspring
right their hair can become shaggier and
their snouts will elongate in order
to allow them to root more effectively
because that's one of their primary
ways of feeding is rooting and that's
the most destructive way i mean they can
dig
three feet down in soft dirt and they're
getting roots to getting insects they're
they're omnivores and they they'll go
after anything
and and so once they get out they go
feral quick they get they get street
smarts
too i mean they go nocturnal i mean
they're smart smart animals
and so you add all this together you
know the the
the herds that were initially brought
here for food and then further domestic
herds and then you have escapees
over hundreds of years of of you know
settling
in this country and you've got escaped
domestic cogs
then you've got hogs specifically
brought in for hunting namely your
russian bores
your eurasian boars um which are kind of
the big hairy razorbacks
how much different are those is it all
it's still the same species right yes it
is
and they're i mean they're they're it's
like i believe and
you know not i don't want to stand by it
but i believe it's just like a
subspecies there's one more latin name
after suscrofa uh for the eurasian
but freely interbreeding it's not like i
mean they're not hybrids where they're
not
well they make hybrids right but the
hybrids are viable absolutely
yes it's not like a hybrid like a liger
where they can't
no no no no no nothing like that and so
then you've got some some
kind of specific areas california had a
lot of russian bores brought in and
there's certain areas in texas
the powderhorn ranch down near port
o'connor was one that
had it bro some brought in specifically
and deposited there
is the difference in the flavor or the
the way they
look like the flesh it would be really
hard to determine that now because most
of them
over the years have interbred with your
standard
feral pig and so purebred
populations of those hogs are very hard
to find
it's debatable whether the powderhorn
ranch population
is purebred russian bore i've read i've
read different things about it
some say that it's not some say that it
is it's a high fence
it's got a high fence around it has had
one since the 1920s i believe
oh wow and so whenever they brought in
the bores
those are the same breeding population
right they think but you know you know a
fence doesn't mean [ __ ] to a pig you
know i go under it you know any way
around it that they can
flood waters come up they can swim you
know it's
so it's it's not known but there is one
sequestered population of
feral hogs in the united states and
that's on osaba
island off the coast of georgia and so
that was an iberico hog
brought over here by the spanish you
know pointy hats long brown robes
they dropped some hogs on that island
and that island has sustained
a population of purebred iberico hogs
to this day and it's called osaba island
and they have an osaba island hog which
is a purebred iberico hog which is the
same hog that produces the 150
150 dollar a pound uh
serrano ham catch new episodes of the
joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience